this is melanoma Monday when we focus on
preventing potentially deadly skin
cancer melanoma is the most serious form
of skin cancer killing more than 8 000
people a year in these United States but
the good news is it is treatable if you
find it early Dr Elizabeth Hale is an
associate professor of Dermatology at
NYU langone and a senior vice president
of the Skin Cancer Foundation thank you
so much for being here uh it's a very
serious issue and skin cancer is going
up in men and people of color why might
that be so we're seeing increases in
skin cancer in all Americans it's
thought that about one in five Americans
will develop skin cancer by age 70 but
we are seeing increases among all skin
types so people of skin of color and
also in men we know that melanoma is
most common in men and they actually
have the highest mortality rate it's
thought perhaps men aren't as good about
wearing sunscreen about seeing a
dermatologist and Men often tend to get
melanoma on their back where it tends to
be most deadly so it's a great idea to
get familiar with your own molds but
also maybe have a partner take a look at
your back as well so what should that
partner be looking for so when you do a
self-exam or have someone in your life
do an exam what what is important to
notice so anything new changing or
unusual should be brought to your
dermatologist attention but when we talk
about moles we talk about the a b c d
e's a is asymmetry B is border
irregularity C is for color variability
D stood for diameter for a long time but
increasingly we talk about D for
Darkness because sometimes that mole is
just so dark it stands out and most
importantly e is evolving so if a mole
is changing I take that very seriously
and I evaluate it closely okay all right
so how often should people in addition
to self-exams be screened by a
dermatologist so we recommend that every
American above age 18 gets an annual
skin examination the thing that's unique
about skin cancer it's so common but
it's also so preventable we know that
about 9 of skin cancers are associated
with sun exposure and also skin cancer
is almost always curable when it's
caught early so it's really important to
protect ourselves to get checked because
early detection is key all right so you
mentioned that men may be getting it
because they're not putting sunscreen on
as much as they should be what should
people in general be looking for in a
sunscreen so we recommend a broad
spectrum SPF 30 or higher and it's
important to think about sunscreen every
single day it's not just enough when
going to the beach or pool because we
know that sun damage is cumulative we
also look for broad spectrum ingredients
like avobenzone zinc oxide and
importantly when you're outside you want
to reapply every two hours even more if
you're sweating or swimming but getting
people to wear it every day I think is
the real the real goal all right I check
a few of those boxes on the men not
applying it every day you know not
getting checked as much as I should but
I'm going to take this as an opportunity
to go ahead and get checked excellent
thank you doctor I appreciate it thanks
for having